>> Greg: IT'S THE GOLDEN AGER
VERSUS THE COLLEGE RAGER.
RESIDENTS OF A SENIOR CITIZEN
DORMITORY ON THE ARIZONA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS, WHO KNEW?
ARE SUING A NEIGHBORING BAR
SAYING IT'S TOO DAM LOUD AT
NIGHT.
THEY ARGUE THE BAR ACROSS THE
STREET GETS SO NOISY IT KEEPS
THEM FROM DOZING OFF.
I HATE THAT.
I USED TO WAKE UP EVERY NIGHT
BEFORE I SWITCHED TO FLOMAX.
BACK IN SPRING, A JUDGE HAD
ORDERED THE SHADY PARK BAR TO
LIMIT THE VOLUME OF OUTDOOR
CONCERTS AND IMPOSE AN
11:00 P.M. CURFEW ON FRIDAYs AND
SATURDAYS BUT THE VENUE APPEALED
ARGUING IT WOULD BE BAD FOR
BUSINESS AND THE CITY OF TEMPE
AGREED SAYING IT'S GOOD FOR A
VIBRANT NEIGHBORHOOD.
SO NOW THE SENIOR CITIZENS, SOME
OF WHOM SPENT A MILLION DOLLARS
TO LIVE AT AXU ARE SUING.
AND YOU DON'T WANT TO MESS WITH
THEM.
THEY'VE GOT TIME ON THEIR HANDS
AND LIVER SPOTS.
BUT LIKE NANCY PELOSI'S SWIM
SUIT --
[GROAN].
>> Greg: WHAT?
I'M NOT EVEN FINISHED.
THE SITUATION IS VERY REVEALING.
IT TELLS YOU EVEN THE ELDERLY
ARE WILLING TO SHELL OUT BIG
BUCKS TO LITERALLY LIVE ON
CAMPUS.
AND I GET IT.
WHAT'S NOT TO LOVE.
YOU GET ALL THE FUN OF DORM
STYLE LIVING BUT AS AN OLDER
WISER ADULT.
AND HOPEFULLY LIKE COLLEGE
YOU'LL BE HOOKING UP.
YOU KNOW.
BUT REMEMBER FELLOWS, IF THERE'S
A SOCK ON THE DOOR, THAT MEANS
YOUR ROOMMATE IS GETTING AN
ENMA.
ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS A REALLY WEIRD STORY,
TYRUS.
>> Tyrus: AND YOU MADE IT SO
MUCH WEIRDER THAN IT NEEDED TO
BE.
>> Greg: BUT, NO, THINK ABOUT
THIS.
SO WE HAVE PROBLEMS WITH
HOUSING.
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS.
WE ALSO HAVE AN ALONE CRISIS.
WE HEAR ABOUT RISES IN
DEPRESSION, OLDER PEOPLE LIVING
ALONE, THERE'S NOT ENOUGH KIDS
TAKING CARE OF THEM.
ISN'T THIS THE IDEA THAT LIKE,
WOULD PEOPLE REMEMBER WHEN I
LIVED IN THE DORM IT WAS FUN?
DIDN'T YOU HAVE A GOOD TIME?
YOU COULD BE A COLLEGE
STUDENT --.
>> Tyrus: WHEN I LOOK BACK AT IT
NOW?
NO I WAS HORRIBLE.
TO MY RA OUT THERE, I HOPE YOU
HEALED UP BRA.
YOU LIVED IN THE DORMS WENT
THROUGH CLASS, FIGURE OUT WHO
WAS BUYING A BEER AND WHAT
MILDLY ATTRACTIVE GIRL HAD A
CAR.
I WAS BROKE YOU LOWER YOUR
SUBJECTS FOR A CAR.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO GO BACK,
BECAUSE EVERYBODY THINKS IT'S
LIKE RODNEY DANGERFIELD GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL AND IT'S GREAT
AND THE OLD GUY'S GREAT.
YOU REALIZE YOU'RE OLDER NOW SO
NOW YOU'RE BACK ON THE CAMPUS
WHERE EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE FUN
AND PARTY AND APPARENTLY YOU
WANT TO GO TO BED AT 8:00.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK IN A
COLLEGE TOWN.
I DON'T FEEL BAD FOR THEM.
I REALLY DON'T.
YOU CHOSE TO LIVE ON CAMPUS.
TRY STAYING IN NEW YORK FOR THE
WEEKEND.
THE WORST PROBLEM I WOULD HAVE
WOULD BE HEARING MUSIC AS
OPPOSED TO, THIS IS MY SPOT,
I'LL KILL YOU, WINDO
WOO WOO,
BOOM BOOM.
YOU KNOW, SO, BE CAREFUL WHAT
YOU WISH FOR, I'LL TAKE SOME
MUSIC.
>> Greg: DO YOU HEAR THINGS AT
MY NIGHT IN NEW YORK THAT ARE
UNEXPLAINABLE.
LIKE SOME GUY JUST SHRIEKING.
>> Shannon: I KNOW.
I'M LIKE IS THAT A CAT IN HEAT
OR A PERSON.
>> Greg: JUST A MALE SHRIEKING
AND YOU GO OUT AND YOU'RE LIKE
HE'S NOT THERE.
I FEEL LIKE THEY'RE DEMONS.
>> Shannon: IT COULD BE RATS,
THEY'RE VERY BIG.
>> Greg: DID YOU EVER HEAR OF
SENIOR CITIZEN DORMS ON CAMPUS.
>> Shannon: HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
THIS OPENED DURING COVID AND THE
CLUBS WERE ALL CLOSED SO PEOPLE
DIDN'T KNOW WHEN THEY PUT THEIR
SEVEN FIGURES DOWN ON THIS THING
THAT THERE WAS GOING TO BE A
PARTY NEXT DOOR AND SO NOW THAT
EVERYTHING'S REOPENED FROM COVID
THEY'RE LIKE OH, THERE'S OTHER
PEOPLE IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD AND
THIS IS A PROBLEM.
I SAY THIS IS KIND OF LIKE THE
VILLAGES, HAVE YOU BEEN WILL?
AMAZING.
THE VILLAGES WOULD CELEBRATE
THIS AND WELCOME THESE CLUBS IN.
>> Greg: I KNOW, KAT, I KNOW
WHAT SIDE YOU'RE GOING TO GO ON
>> Kat: OF COURSE.
>> Greg: THINK ABOUT THE
PARTIERS
>> Kat: THERE'S ONLY ONE SIDE.
THEY MOVED, THEY MOVE INTO A
PLACE THAT'S RIGHT NEXT TO LIKE
A TECHNO CLUB AT ARIZONA STATE
AND THEY'RE LIKE, IT'S LOUD.
NO [BLEEP], GAYLE.
>> Tyrus: YOU KNOW THERE'S A
GAYLE, YOU KNOW THERE'S A GAYLE
>> Kat: GAYLE FISH P, SHE SAID
IT DOESN'T MEAN BOOM BOOM BOOM
ALL NIGHT.
YES IT DOES BROTHER.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WE JUST WANT IT TO BE QUIET ON
FRIDAYS AND SATURDAYS AT
11:00 P.M. WE'RE NOT BEING
UNREASONABLE.
THAT IS THE DEFINITION OF
YOU WANT ARIZONA STATE KIDS TO
BE SNUGGLED UP IN BED AT
11:00 P.M.
I WANT TO GO THERE AND STAND
OUTSIDE THE WINDOW AND SCREAM.
>> Tyrus: HEY, CAN'T THEY --
CAN'T --
>> Kat: GO ANYWHERE ELSE.
>> Tyrus: CAN'T THEY TAKE THEIR
FRUIT AND VEGGIE PILLS AND GET
THEIR VA VA VIM BACK?
>> Greg: I LOVE -- THOSE FRUIT
AND VEGGIE PILLS HAVE CHANGED MY
LIFE!
ALL RIGHT, JIMMY I'M GOING TO
KEEP HAR PINNING ON THIS.
THIS COULD BE THE SOLUTION,
THOUGH, DORM LIVING FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE RETIRED BECAUSE, AGAIN,
IF YOU'RE ALONE -- THE GREAT
THING ABOUT COLLEGE DORM LIFE OR
FRATERNITIES IS THAT THERE WAS
ALWAYS SOMEBODY TO DO SOMETHING
WITH
>> Jimmy: THANK YOU AND THEY'RE
ALWAYS LONELY.
THE MOST TRAGIC THING ABOUT THIS
IS IT'S AT ARIZONA STATE WHICH
IS LIKE THE BIGGEST PARTY SCHOOL
EVER.
LIKE WHEN A KID THERE GETS A 4.0
THEY'RE TALKING BLOOD ALCOHOL
CONTENT, NOT GRADES.
BUT YOU UNDERSTAND LIKE SHANNON
MADE THE POINT, KAT KIND OF MADE
THE POINT, TY MADE THE POINT,
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO LEAN IN.
IF YOU'RE MOVING INTO A COLLEGE
DORM IT'S BECAUSE YOU CULTIVATED
THAT ENVIRONMENT AND IN THE
FIELD GOOD VERSION IT'S GOING TO
END WITH THEM LEANING IN AND
BECOMING THE VILLAGES IN
FLORIDA.
BY THE TIME THIS IS OVER THERE
WILL BE A PORN SIGHT CALLED HIT
GRANNY IN THE FANNY.COM.
THEY'LL HAVE LIKE A MILLION
DOLLARS EVERYONE CAN PAY THEIR
STUDENT LOANS PROBLEM SOLVED.
>> Greg: YOU'RE TALKING LIKE A
REVENGE OF THE IN OTHER WORDS
STYLE MOVIE WHERE IT'S THE
SENIOR CITIZEN DORM THAT ENDS UP
OUTPARTYING EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> Jimmy: IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT'S INEVITABLE.
>> Greg: THEN THEY BUILD LIKE A
FLOAT ON H